salió el sol en Brasilia y los más
madrugadores ya estaban preparados para
votar es un día especial
nuestra democracia está constantemente
cuestionada es una alegría para nosotros
poder votar hoy
largas filas en los barrios más
populares donde suelen votar más a la
izquierda como en rochina la Favela más
grande de Río de Janeiro
la salud está complicada la seguridad
está pésima la inflación está muy alta
pero más allá de Brasil la diáspora
lleva botando todo el día Así estaba
Lisboa
y así Barcelona pero el momento más
esperado de la jornada era ver a Los
favoritos Este es el voto del
expresidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
quien lo hizo primero
cuatro años después Estoy aquí votando
con el reconocimiento de mi libertad
plena y con la posibilidad de volver a
ser presidente de este país para
intentar que este país vuelva a la
normalidad
Poco después con camiseta patriótica el
presidente Jair bolsonaro quien prepara
con su discurso el terreno ante una
posible derrota
lo que importa es la voz del pueblo lo
que importa es eso elecciones limpias y
sin problemas que gane el mejor
va a respetar los resultados de las
elecciones
la cuarta democracia más grande del
mundo se debate entre una vuelta a la
izquierda o continuar por el camino de
la ultraderecha la duda según los
sondeos es si el expresidente Lula puede
lograr la victoria en primera vuelta
alcanzando el 50% de los